- Hi, I'm Sal Khan.
Founder of the Khan Academy.
We're a not for profit with a mission
of providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere.
There are tens of millions of people
learning on Khan Academy
who wanna prove what they know,
who wanna show the world
they're just as capable
as folks with more traditional diplomas.
So we're gonna make a bridge
between learning on Khan Academy
and real economic opportunity.
To do that, we're gonna work with
employers and universities
all over the world
to identify the skills
that people need most
to be successful.
Then we'll build the content and the tools
that allow anyone,
starting from any level,
to learn those skills.
To build the bridge between
the learning of the skills
and the opportunities
where you can apply them,
we're gonna create globally
recognized diplomas.
We're confident we can do this,
because we already have
the reach and credibility
with over 100 million
learners all over the world,
and we have partnerships in assessment,
in industry, and in higher education.
Together, I believe that we can do this.
And when it happens,
it's going to bring hope and opportunity
to people all over the world.
- When you see Khan Academy,
it gives you hope that there is
someone who can bring change,
and I'm hopeful that they
will be able to reach to
hundreds and thousands
or millions of children across the world,
and allow them and help
them to be empowered.
I believe in that.